i'm gonna get into work at 8 30 before
anybody else i'm going to leave after
everybody else i'm going to go home i'm
going to read read read
that's work that's not life and i was
like you know what i need
just a little bit of life because i've
seen these films i've made a few
i know if if i can ingest more of the
world i can reflect more of it
i think stereotypes come from without
not from within so
to me these characters aren't any type
you know they're they're actual people
that tyrell and i either knew or
or were i think the fact that we're
seeing this work right now means we
probably were in that moment
a few years ago and i had this almost
this barrier where i thought oh can a
straight man
tell the story so i was terrified
when i initially read it but it was
about
taking ownership of the piece i wasn't
sure if i could fully do that but our
lives
are so damn similar i mean down to the t
and i thought if if i can't empathize
with this with this character
then i'm saying something fundamentally
uh [ __ ] up
about uh sexuality and what it means for
humanity versus inhumanity
so for a year i buried myself and buried
myself because i had a question in my
head
that i didn't want anyone to ask me
before i answered for myself and that
question was
is this guy not good enough for this
program because he's black
and he's poor he grew up with the mama
to the drugs
or does he just not know you need light
to expose film
and i'm going to read as much film
criticism as i possibly can i'm going to
open the field of my experience as wide
as possible
and then i'm going to come back and when
i come back i'm going to show
[Music]
uh you know it's it's funny i was
terrified of making this film initially
you know uh if you read anything about
this movie you will read that barry
jenkins is straight and terrell mccraney
is gay
and uh and i had this almost this
barrier where i thought oh can a
straight man
uh tell the story because i believe
there are certain narratives that
they can be told without a first person
perspective or first person experience
but
to maximize the potential the
possibility of the feeling you need a
first person
perspective and i didn't have that for
certain elements of this film
so i was terrified when i initially read
it
but it was about taking ownership of the
piece i wasn't sure if i could fully do
that but our lives are so damn similar i
mean
down to the t and i thought if if i
can't
empathize with this with this character
then i'm saying something fundamentally
uh [ __ ] up about uh sexuality and what
it means for humanity versus inhumanity
i was like i just can't abide by that so
i'm going to
take ownership of this piece um fall in
love with this character
and and place myself within his being
and so i did that
and we got on with it florida state's a
very good film program they paid for
everything we shot everything on film
it's a great training ground and then i
got to la and nobody gives a [ __ ]
about anything you want to do and uh and
for those two years
i kind of like fell out of love with
filmmaking because i thought i don't
want to be nobody's assistant
and what age was that i was 25 which is
the worst thing a 25 year old in la
who's
won a director's assistant on a movie
produced by oprah winfrey starring halle
berry
within three months of graduating and
then is working in
harpo films reading books reading
screenplays i thought that ain't good
enough
uh it but but then this really cool
thing happened
you're right i'm telling my bio now so
uh i
i had gotten this grant for five
thousand dollars when i graduated from
florida state it was how i was
able to afford to move out here uh and
it was this thing called the pathfinder
award
and then when i realized that i wasn't
working out at harpo
they gave they had a 401k this is like
2007 2006.
and the 401k ms winfrey has great
benefits at her company
she is very good to her employees my
dumb ass
i was like you know what i'm going to
cash out my 401k
so i took like the 55 60 tax that you
have to pay when you cash out a 401k
early but it was so robust that i had
like seven grand
just in the year and a half i worked for
her and i was like now i'm gonna do what
i wanted to do when i graduated which is
i'm gonna do what the white people do
i'm gonna go to europe and go
backpacking i want to see the world
however however
i learned very quickly i learned very
quickly that seven thousand dollars
would not go very far
backpacking in europe uh so i took
trains around the us
for a whole year i gave my car the car
darnell gave to me i paid it for it i
gave it to some church like a church
charity
and uh and i just took trains for a year
i go to san francisco for two months
i go to new york uh dc chicago went back
to florida
what was the intention what was this i
just i just
felt like i lived my whole life in
basically
in this very small world in miami i
hadn't seen anything of the world
falling in love with cinema and film
school i realized wow it's a very big
world
bigger than my eight blocks and i was
like i want to see some of that but i
came to la
and everybody here works in the industry
if you're doing it the proper way it is
furious you have to be like i'm gonna
get into work at 8 30 before anybody
else i'm going to leave after everybody
else i'm going to go home i'm going to
read read read
that's work that's not life and i was
like you know what i need
just a little bit of life because i've
seen these films i've made a few
i know if if i can ingest more of the
world i can reflect more of it
and and so i thought well i can't go to
europe but i'm just going to touch
every piece of the us i can and it was
very lonely but it was very very
certain points in your life over the
course of your career but i want to say
in your life and your career
you have to be real with yourself one
semester
into film school i think i changed my
own life by just being real with myself
i was a terrible terrible film student
terrible because i didn't have the tools
uh to know how to utilize my voice uh in
the realm of filmmaking
so i went to the dean i said dean i love
being here
i really wanted to be here thank you so
much for inviting me
into this program i need to leave i went
to the dean and said to him
i do not want to continue in film school
right now i said to him
i don't want to continue right now
because i do not have the skills that my
classmates have
would you please give me a year to leave
this program
bring myself up to speed and i will come
back and i promise you i will not waste
this slot
and he said yes dean frank patterson
said yes and so i literally took a year
off film school
i had started a creative writing degree
and i thought oh i'll just go
and somehow i'll become the six-year
undergrad student by finishing my
creative writing degree
while doing what i described independent
study some of you probably heard the
story before
i took a still photography class i went
to blockbuster video
and watched the forward film section and
i watched every single forward film
that was on the shelf there was a
science library on campus called the
dirac science library changed my life
because in the top floors we had all
these things about chemicals and cells
and biology
and then the basement in the basement
the lord knows what reason
you had this treasure trove of art books
you had masters of light
you had thought to the cinematographer
just all these things
so for a year i buried myself and buried
myself because i had a question in my
head
that i didn't want anyone to ask me
before i answered for myself and that
question was
is this guy not good enough for this
program because he's black
and he's poor he grew up with the mama
to the drugs
or does he just not know you need light
to expose film
and so i took that year off and i said
you know what
i'm going to learn how to expose him
better than anybody else in this program
you know and i'm going to read and
listen to as many dvd commentaries as
possible
i'm going to find the most obscure uh
film journal that's written in english
which was sight and sound because i
couldn't
uh i couldn't translate kahuna for
myself
and i'm going to read as much film
criticism as i possibly can i'm going to
open the field of my experience as wide
as possible
and then i'm going to come back and when
i come back i'm going to show
them i'm going to show every damn body i
think stereotypes come from without not
from within so
to me these characters aren't any type
you know they're they're actual people
that uh tyrell and i either knew or
or were i think we have characters in
this movie that you don't see very often
represented in arts and letters and i
think the way the actors
like give those act those characters
like a full
fully fleshed out and lived in voice is
the reason why
people are identifying so much with
the characters in our story and that to
me is fully
uh a testament to the quality of the
acting and
if you know the people in this movie
don't go on to do
more work uh then i would i would say
that's an indictment
of the system because clearly the talent
is there i want
people to be able to explore their
passions and fulfill their dreams you
know
now it depends on what dreams you have
you know if you have a dream
a winning best picture i can't tell you
to pursue that dream
that's not something to be pursued you
know if you have a story
you very very viscerally want to tell i
want you
to uh to have whatever resources you
need
uh to realize that dream you know and i
think over the
course of the next 10 years i also hope
too that we create enough spaces
for everyone especially for people who
have not
been allowed the space who've been
denied the space of television streams
to do so perfect example we're going to
implicate myself here
i was scheduled to give this keynote
from 11 to noon now there's a filmmaker
uh named nigel who has a film called jim
that somehow is also screaming at 11 30
this morning
there's also the wrap has no screen
right now
but it's also screening tomorrow and
then the wrap also has
a women in power breakfast that's
happening right now
and so inadvertently i a person
both a man and someone who won best
picture
i'm taking up space from a young female
director who's having our world premiere
right now
and this group of women that are
discussing things that are very
important to the industry so
i hope that over the course of the next
10 years there's enough space for all
those things to happen
and at the space i take a doesn't deny
anyone access to
the same space that's my dream i was
wondering if you could talk a bit more
about
the colors in the movie and sort of um
like the story you're trying to tell
through the colors i just
i was so blown away by like every single
scene and like how i felt like there was
a specific
thing happening with the colors and
you're already doing it in the
medicine for melancholy also yeah yeah a
little bit we try not to be
too uh too overt with the color blocking
uh in the films
uh celine skiama did a beautiful job
with it in the film girl hood
um with the color blue and i saw that
film and unfortunately
i was like well [ __ ] we can't do that
because our moonlight our movie's called
and moonlight black boys look blue
so we tried to be a bit more subtle with
it i think in the third chapter the
color blue
takes on a bit more resonance than it
does uh in the early parts but
again movies meant to be an immersive
experience uh for the audience so the
times we're most aggressive with the
color blocking
are times when it's in the consciousness
of charon so and the second story when
he has the dream
uh about uh about kevin and the third
story when he has the dream about kevin
that's when we're doing very aggressive
things uh with the color uh for me the
most uh
the most uh visually uh thematic thing
we did with color was all about uh the
paula character
in the first story there's this this
light at the end of this hallway
and uh again working intuitively i
remember getting to set because naomi's
work we have to do in three days and
if anybody sees the film tonight i'm
gonna retell some of these stories i
apologize
uh we had to do all her work in three
days and so we only had her
in each location one time and uh when
you work that way you have to utilize
the location
as much as possible and i remember
getting to this apartment
and looking down the hallway and real
realizing that this hallway symbolized
this distance that cannot be traversed
by these two characters and i knew we
wouldn't production wise go in the
bedroom because we couldn't afford to
production design it
but i want the bedroom to have a
presence as this place that shyron
cannot go
this place of darkness for his mom and
we tried to i don't know if there's like
there's a freudian or kenzian thing
something with like color temperature
and how it relates to psychology
and we kind of looked it up a little bit
and then we went in the room and we just
started dialing up this color like
literally
manually dialing it up the color
temperature and we ended up with that
sort of like
pink that's right we're in holland we
end up with that pink red light
symbolizing this thing uh for sharon's
mom and what goes on back there and so
it wasn't about trying to chart a path
across the film
but there were certain places where uh
the spirit of charon moved us
and so we did a little thing yeah
was uh amazing and so i moved to san
francisco
for that woman and of course it was
great it was awesome
and it was not so awesome and then i was
dumped
so i started writing and i wrote a few
screenplays and then i wrote this one
medicine for melancholy i got the script
together and sent it off
to the contacts i had made in hollywood
it was a really small
low budget film so i assumed somebody's
going to open this pack and just be like
you know here's the money go make your
film that did not happen
as a filmmaker i was absolutely like
just on the bottom
bottom bottom i thought so little of
myself and didn't think i was capable of
doing so many things
i called i called my friends and and
part of that call was just to come
complain around my man can you believe
nobody called me back and blah blah blah
and then uh it was justin who said you
know whoa
what are you doing what are you doing
this you don't you don't need that you
know it's totally fine you know we're
still gonna make the movie
and it was just then you know applying
the ingenuity we learned at film school
and going okay
we can't do it that way you know but
let's see how we can do it this way
everybody who worked on the film was a
person i went to film school with
this movie would not have happened
without without those friends
once we started it was like this huge
ball that was just going to absolutely
keep rolling downhill no matter what
and so it was an absolutely amazing
experience
and we saw it on every show and it's a
film made by five people in san
francisco with no stars in it
[Music]
i always remember the one of the very
last things that a professor said to us
in film school was
he said look to your left look to your
right the most talented people you will
ever work with are sitting in this
classroom with you right now
and the people who will only only ever
tell you yes
we'll never tell you no sitting in this
classroom with you right now
please remember that and i love how in
moonlight
the music and the images really
worked really well together and can you
tell
tell me a little bit about um the reason
behind the choice of music you made
because i listened to the playlist on
spotify from moonlight
without the images and it still tells
the story itself
so yeah that's uh the last comment is is
key
you know we i knew the kind of music i
wanted in the film
and some of the music is written into
the screenplay like the barbara lewis
song that plays
and the diner is written to the
screenplay the lyrics are literally
written
into the screenplay but then the score
is this whole other thing
um i knew uh the tone of score i wanted
i knew the instrument instrumentation i
wanted that it was going to be
sort of a chamber orchestra but we
didn't try to start composing music
before we had the film
the composer nicholas patel academy
award nominee nicholas patel
um he was uh very cool about he lives in
new york i live in la
and after we had a pretty good cut of
the film when the film was like 90
what it was going to be i started going
out there and your last comment is key
because
rather than him writing music and us
trying it in the film
he would sit together and we would watch
the movie and then we would
you know play certain demos
instrumentation
for the film and what happened was we
did it in sequence
and so as the character evolves uh the
score evolved
as well to the point that if you've read
anything about the music in this film or
have you seen the movie
near the end of the film the characters
becoming more masculine and we have this
hip-hop in the states
you know he's like that's a good test
audience if i say chopped and screwed
does anybody know what that is can you
raise a hand
so chopped and screwed is a style of
hip-hop in the states
primarily in texas but also in florida
where they slow hip-hop
down and they alter the pitch it gets
very bassy
and quote-unquote very masculine but in
this masculinity
uh the lyrics are slower so now you can
actually hear what people are saying
there's a lot of pain and yearning in
hip-hop but the bpms are so fast
that we often don't catch it uh so when
chopped and screwed
all these screw artists think they're
making the music sound a lot tougher but
they're actually making it
uh sound is way more sensitive and
vulnerable and so
and the film the hip hop the source cues
are getting more masculine as the film
goes on
and nick because we're watching the film
we're telling the story with the music
he started chopping and screwing the
violins as well
um and so it's this beautiful thing
where i do agree if you take the film
and take the images away and let's
listen to the score nick is also telling
uh a story to the point that our end
credits suite
that cue there's a song that plays on
the beach uh
during the the the most uh sexually
averse scene in the film
it plays again in the kitchen and then
there's a song that that plays when
kevin is making the chef special
the in credit suite uh is a journey back
through the film
chopping and screwing those three cues
and then coming out of chopping and
screwing to
the character's birth with his violin uh
and
cello so and piano so great observation
and i think the reason why
it feels that way is because rather than
imposing music on the film
uh nick and i would watch the movie and
let the characters tell us what was
appropriate
uh in the score with both janelle and
naomi you know i think both those roles
are difficult in different ways you know
um you know with uh janelle she'd never
acted before you know and yet she
related to the character like
immensely on a very visceral level with
naomi
it was a challenge you know i i wanted
someone who had
very good chops as they say and naomi
has very good chops
but she's nothing like that character
you know so it was about research
and trust and just kind of going for it
and she came to miami man and she just
went for it and it's she's playing the
character that to me
is most personally related to my
biography she's playing basically
a composite of my mom and tyrell's mom
and so it was really difficult
working with her on the film because i
mean at that point it's like
i'm reliving my life you know in the
present tense you know with this
fantastic actor you know but i need to
separate that because we have a
character and we've got to build
and every step of the way when i asked
naomi to do something you know i'd
explain
why and she would explain how she felt
and we'll just go for it
you